-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "the Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Happy Monday.
Today is Cyber Monday.
Yeah.
I love shopping on Cyber Monday,
'cause nothing beats spending
the holiday season
on hold with the Bank of America
fraud department.
[ Laughter ]
"Huh?
No, I didn't buy a TV from
Walmart in the Philippines.
No, that wasn't me."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, over 60 million people
bought gifts today,
yet somehow, on Christmas, all
we do is exchange gift cards.
How does that work?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
But it was a big day.
Amazon offered tons of deals,
Target rolled out
major discounts,
and RadioShack was like, "We
should really get a website."
[ Laughter ]
"We should do that.
Maybe next year.
Make a note."
Yep, most people
prefer online shopping
because it's easier
and because we're tired of
having to sadly raise our hand
at the self-checkout machines.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm an adult who needs help.
Thanks."
[ Laughter ]
"Do I weigh my bag,
or give me the bag, and --
Just give me --
I'll buy two bags.
What is --"
[ Applause ]
"How did it know that I didn't
put the thing in the bag."
[ Laughter ]
What's going on?
Meanwhile, today, in Washington,
First Lady Jill Biden revealed
this year's
White House holiday decorations.
There are 41 Christmas trees
and almost 80,000 lights.
Meanwhile, the family
at 1602 Pennsylvania Avenue
is like, "They always
have to one-up us every year.
They gotta one-up."
The theme
of this year's decorations
is Gifts from the Heart.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
As opposed to today's theme,
Gifts I Found Online
for 60% Off.
[ Laughter ]
Kinda from the heart, yeah.
Yet there are 41 Christmas trees
in the White House,
and even former President Trump
made it onto
one of the ornaments.
This is real.
This is a real ornament.
Take a look at this.
You see him?
There he is.
[ Laughter ]
You know that's definitely
on the side of the tree
that faces the wall, you know?
[ Laughter ]
"You made that yourself?
Let me hang it up."
[ Applause ]
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
amazing, amazing.
It looks like a reindeer.
It looks just like you made a
reindeer out of pop sticks.
There you go, back there.
[ Laughter ]
'Course, the big news
that everyone is talking about
is this new COVID variant,
called omicron.
Yeah, we need another variant
like we another
turkey sandwich for lunch.
[ Laughter ]
Omicron.
It sounds like a Transformer
who can't smell or taste.
[ Laughter ]
"Omicron!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're getting kind of deep
in the Greek alphabet, you know?
Pretty soon, we're gonna
run out of letters
and just start using Gatorade
flavors, you know?
Fauci will be like,
"We have to do whatever it takes
to stop
the fierce melon variant."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, basically,
everyone is bummed out
about the new variant.
Meanwhile, Delta Airlines
is like, "Oh, yeah!
Hey-ya!
What's up?!
I knew we were gonna --
Come on!"
[ Laughter ]
But the White House
is trying to handle it today.
President Biden
held a press conference,
and he told Americans
that the new variant
is a cause for concern,
not a cause for panic.
Americans heard and were like,
"Well, in that case,
we'll just buy 10 pallets of
toilet paper instead of 12."
[ Laughter ]
But the White House said
it will take two weeks
to have definitive data
on the new strain.
That's right, even our COVID
information has shipping delays.
[ Laughter ]
Unbelievable.
[ Applause ]
Of course -- [ Chuckles ]
Of course, Biden told everyone
to get their booster.
And he said
to carve out some time,
because rolling up your sleeves
takes longer than you think.
-Is the First Lady getting one,
as well, Mr. President?
-She's gonna get one.
I think she's teaching.
But she's gonna get one, yes.
-Mr. President
what do you say...
-What in the world?!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Oh, my gosh.
At that point,
Just take your shirt off.
What are we --
What is going on?
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Never seen anything like it.
Some major business news.
Today, Jack Dorsey stepped down
as the CEO of Twitter.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Yep.
Twitter hopes
that his replacement can find
new and exciting ways
for strangers
to say horrible things
to each other.
[ Laughter ]
I think Dorsey
made the right decision, though.
It seems like the job
really took a toll on him.
Here he is nine years ago.
That's him.
And here he is today.
This is real.
[ Laughter ]
Even Obama's like,
"Man, that job really aged you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's real.
I mean...
It's definitely a sign to leave
your job when you're 45
and you look like Tom Hanks
at the end of "Castaway."
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Some news from overseas.
Apparently, Kim Jong-un
banned leather coats
in North Korea
so that nobody
can copy his style.
[ Laughter ]
This is real.
Can we see him
in his leather jacket?
-Yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
Right now, there's a giant
police raid in the sofa section
at Raymour & Flanigan.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this -- due to
a huge snowstorm in the U.K.,
more than 60 people, including
members of an Oasis cover band,
have been stuck in a pub
since Friday night.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
After three days,
everyone was fighting
with each other.
It was almost like
they were in the band Oasis.
[ Laughter ]
Almost.
And finally,
this is going viral.
Someone filmed a fellow driver
on the highway
with a Christmas tree
that might have been
just a bit too big
for their car.
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-He was like,
"This is gonna look great
in my studio apartment."
Well, guys, Pfizer and Moderna
both say
that they're already working
on vaccines
for the Omicron variant.
While Johnson & Johnson
is cheering them on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, Johnson & Johnson is like,
"Guys, I thought we promised
we're not doing vaccines
this year.
[ Laughter ]
Why would you embarrass me?"
How'd they start working on this
so fast, too?
It's like when a team
wins the Super Bowl
and the first commercial is,
"Buy your
Buccaneers Championship
hat now!"
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "Wait."
Meanwhile, officials
just announced
that Omicron was present
in Amsterdam 11 days ago.
[ Audience oohs ]
It took a while to catch it
because, in Amsterdam,
there's a very different meaning
to "a new strain going around."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Clears throat ]
Yeah.
Certain sections of our audience
got that faster
[ Laughter and applause ]
than others.
Yeah, following the news
on the Omicron variant,
the CDC is now saying
that all adults
should get a booster shot.
Right now, Instagram is like,
"Incoming booster selfies
in 3, 2, 1!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
tomorrow's December 1st
and everyone's starting
to decorate for the holidays,
so, the FAA
is warning people not
to shine laser light displays
into the sky.
[ Laughter ]
The pilots are actually fine
with the lasers.
It's the emotional support cats
onboard that go nuts.
[ Laughter ]
They're just like --
[ Applause ]
Well, this is cool --
Roomba updated
its latest vacuum cleaner
so that they use AI
to avoid knocking over
Christmas trees.
[ Laughter ]
But don't worry --
with the new update,
your Roombas will still inhale
the tree skirt,
until it blows up
and burns your house down.
[ Laughter ]
It was kind of weird
when the Roomba
kept knocking over the
Christmas tree and then going --
[ Robotic voice ]
Hanukkah rules.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that a new study said
that babies start to develop
a sense of humor
after one month.
It's pretty obvious
when your baby's like --
[ As Jerry Seinfeld ]
What's the deal with naps?
[ Laughter ]
What am I so tired from?
All I did before this
was sleep!
[ Laughter ]
Soft foods, wearing diapers,
napping before sleep --
I'm turning into Grandpa!
[ Laughter ]
I wrote a full-on Seinfeld
-Wow.
Fantastic.
-stand-up act as a baby, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- I read that,
this year, in America,
210 million packages
have already been stolen.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah, it turns out
those Ring doorbells
were a lot more effective
before everyone started
wearing masks.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Uh, yes,
two humans?
I don't know.
Does that help you, Officer?
It wasn't a coyote that took
the package, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
Finally, police in Germany
are looking for burglars
who broke through the wall
of a toy store
to steal dozens of LEGO sets.
The store was like,
"Ah, maybe we shouldn't have
built that wall with DUPLOs."
[ Laughter ]
The thieves got away,
but said their one regret was
robbing the place barefoot.
Ow!
Well, guys tonight was
the 89th annual
Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree lighting.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is the most beautiful thing
you can see in Rockefeller Plaza
besides ice skaters
falling down.
It really is. I think so.
[ Laughter ]
Having a giant tree outside
is great, though.
It is that special time of year
when Rockefeller Center smells
like the inside of an Uber.
Don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
The tree really is
a sight to behold, though.
It's decorated with
more than 50,000 lights.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
Then, one guy
plugged in his Tesla
and the whole city blacked out.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-"Got to charge it up, dude!"
If that's not enough,
the tree is topped with a star
covered in 3 million crystals.
And one construction worker
they forgot to bring down.
"Help! Hey!"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, thousands of people
were in attendance.
Thousands of people.
Even the tree was like,
"Um, can everyone
just throw on a mask
and take like six steps back,
please?"
People were waiting outside
for the tree lighting all day.
After a few hours,
one guy was like,
"I can't remember
which is my pee bottle
and which is
my hot cider bottle."
[ Audience groans ]
"It happens everybody year!"
[ Rim shot ]
[ Laughter ]
"I got to get a label maker
next year."
[ Laughter ]
"I got to charge my Tesla."
Meanwhile, earlier,
in the White House,
on the fourth night of Hanukkah,
President Biden
hosted a menorah lighting.
Nothing says you really care
about a holiday
like waiting until the
fourth night to celebrate.
That's what I...
[ Laughter ]
There was a fun moment tonight
when Biden looked at the menorah
and said, "When I was a kid,
we called this a flashlight."
[ Laughter ]
Some more news -- an FDA panel
just voted 13-10
to narrowly endorse Merck's
anti-viral COVID pill.
Yeah, when it comes
to medication,
I'm not sure "narrowly endorsed"
is the phrase you want to hear.
[ Laughter ]
The drug, they said,
is only 30% effective.
[ Laughter ]
For context, that's only 30%
more effective than a calzone.
Just putting it in context.
[ Laughter ]
Some political news --
Dr. Oz officially announced
that he is running for
U.S. Senate in Pennsylvania.
Yeah, he's diving right in.
And he's even testing out
some campaign slogans
to see what people respond to.
-Really?
-Yep, check some of these out.
First up, there's,
"Dr. Oz -- make America turn
their head and cough again."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Next, there's "Dr. Oz --
stick around after the break.
I'm talking to people
who can't sneeze."
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-Yeah, that's an episode.
-[ Laughs ]
-He's also trying out,
"Dr. Oz, just call me
'Dr. Philly!'
Wait, that doesn't work."
[ Laughter ]
Up next, there's,
"Dr. Oz -- I know Oprah."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Followed by, "Dr. Oz --
no, really, I know her."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, "Dr. Oz --
I mean, we haven't really
spoken recently,
but she gives my texts
a 'thumbs up' sometimes."
Fast one.
[ Applause ]
[ Chuckling ]
Uh, hey, did you guys
hear about this?
CNN has suspended Chris Cuomo
indefinitely
for his role in advising
his brother Andrew Cuomo
during his recent scandal.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah.
Chris Cuomo
knew something was up
when CNN added a suspension
countdown clock.
Yeah, you could tell
Cuomo really misses CNN.
Today he walked up
to a pair of strangers
and asked if he could stand
between them
while they yell at each other.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
This is exciting, actually.
Get this.
Walmart -- love Walmart --
Walmart is selling a baking kit
with everything you need to make
a family-sized Twinkie.
[ Cheers ]
Move over, Pfizer and Moderna.
We got a new favorite for
the Nobel Prize right here!
Family-size Twinkie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Seriously, where was this kit
when we were all buying
sourdough starters?
I mean, come on.
The great thing about Twinkies
is that you can serve it as a
Christmas dessert this year.
And if you don't finish it,
it'll be fresh for next year.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I saw that Cardi B
is launching
her own line of vodka-infused
whipped cream.
[ Audience groans ]
Thank God.
Something to help me forget
I just sprayed an entire can
of whipped cream in my mouth.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Higgins you can bring it --
-I know,
I should have brought it
to the nativity scene.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God, Cardi.
-Luckily, it's non-dairy
for all the health-conscious
vodka-infused whipped-cream
eaters out there.
But this is great.
You squirt a little of that
inside a family-size Twinkie,
now, that's a party.
in Washington, D.C.,
President Biden attended
the 99th annual National
Christmas Tree Lighting.
Meanwhile the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree was like,
"Uh, yeah, sure, that's
the national Christmas tree."
And this was special.
A real-life Elf on the Shelf
made an appearance.
Yeah, he got up and said,
"For the last time,
my name is Pete Buttigieg."
[ Laughter ]
Then organizers said,
"Sorry. Here's the real
Elf on the Shelf."
And then he got up and said,
"I'm sorry. For the last time,
my name is Dr. Fauci."
This is terrible.
Who's writing these?
That's right.
By all accounts,
it was a great time.
I mean, it definitely
went better
than Boris Johnson's
tree lighting in the U.K.
This is real. Look at this.
-Five, four, three, two, one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Aww.
-"Yea-- Ohh.
All right. Go home, everybody."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
Earlier today, President Biden
revealed his plan to fight COVID
this winter, which includes
free at-home testing,
a public education campaign,
and no lockdowns.
And everyone was like,
"Let's not rule out
day drinking so fast."
I mean, that's --
That's right. No lockdowns.
Biden must have felt the glare
of a million brides
planning their wedding.
Like, "Don't you dare.
Don't you dare."
Biden's plan
also extends the mandate
requiring people to wear masks
on public transit.
Then people riding the New
York City subway here were like,
"Yeah, can you also require
a mandate to wear pants?
Because masks are, like,
eighth on the list
of what's happening here."
[ Applause ]
"Ohh! Applesauce."
-"Don't grab the pole!"
[ Laughter ]
-But Biden did lay out
an ambitious goal.
By springtime, he wants
the majority of Americans
to know
how to pronounce "omicron."
-It's called the omnicron.
Omnicron. Omnicron.
The omnicron variant.
[ Laughter ]
-Ombicrombie and Fitch.
I read that President Trump
might have tried
to self-publish his memoir
to avoid getting
a smaller advance
than President Obama
got for his memoir.
Yeah, and Trump
is even considering
a few titles for his book.
For example...
-Oh, here we go.
-What's up, Mark?
-Let me guess.
You're gonna make fun of Trump
by saying a bunch
of fake book titles.
-I mean, yeah,
that was the plan.
-Oh, let me guess.
And then each cover
will pop up on the screen,
and people will see it
and laugh about it.
-Right. We often show graphics
during the monologue
to make our audience laugh.
-Man, I know exactly
how this will go down.
You'll start off with something
like, "Tweet Pray Love."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, then you'll
follow it up with,
"Oh, the Places You'll Riot!"
-Yeah, then you'll do,
"Are You There Vlad?
It's me, Donald."
-Yeah.
-Oh, oh, and after that,
you're gonna do,
"Fifty Shades of COVID."
-Yep. Yeah, these are all
pretty good examples. Yeah.
-Oh, and then you'll do one
that says,
"Lord of the Onion Rings."
-Wait, wait. No, no.
You'll do, "From Whom
the Taco Bell Tolls."
-Yeah.
And then instead of "Clifford
the Big Red Dog," you'll do,
"Clip-On the Big Red Tie."
-Yeah, I know.
But these are -- We probably
wouldn't do this many.
But, yeah,
these are all great examples.
-Oh, then you'll do,
"Nineteen Eighty
Four Seasons Total Landscaping."
-Yeah, exactly.
-Or a couple where you don't
even have to change
the title like,
"Pride and Prejudice"
or "Eclipse."
-Ah! Whoa, whoa.
And then you'll finish it off
with something classic like...
-"The Color Orange."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Is that how
it's gonna go down, Jimbo?
-Yeah, yeah.
You guys nailed it. That was it.
Yeah.
-That sounds like a fun bit.
You should do it.
-All right.
We'll do it tomorrow.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
This is exciting.
Tonight "Annie Live!"
premiered on NBC. Yeah.
It's been a tough year, so NBC
wanted to lift our spirits
with an orphan singing
about how hard life is.
Some business news.
Tesla just announced
two new products
that are kind of surprising.
First they released
a $50 whistle,
and it sold out immediately.
Then they released
a $2,000 ATV for kids
called the Cyberquad.
Take a look at this.
Or as parents put it,
"Yeah, here is a whistle.
Merry Christmas.
They were out of the quad.
Yeah."
Oh, on CNN this morning,
they were talking about
the dangers
of social media for kids.
And one guy had
a very interesting take.
Listen to this.
-You know, in your view,
how harmful
is Instagram to kids?
-Think a lot of parents
would agree with me on this.
I would you rather give
my 14-year-old son
a bottle of Jack Daniel's
and marijuana
than an Instagram
and a Snap account.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-His kid was like, "Okay,
so I guess I'll be drunk,
high, and on TikTok.
Perfect."
His son doesn't need
social media.
He's about to be the
most popular kid at school.
Last night was
the National Christmas Tree
Lighting
and, during his speech,
President Biden tried
to thank LL Cool J for hosting.
But I think he was a little
confused about who LL Cool J is.
[ Laughter ]
Watch this.
-A special thanks
to "The Tonight Show's"
[ Monotone ]
LL Cool J.
[ Laughter ]
I tell you, what, man.
He looks like he can still play.
And I'm not talking
about instruments.
I'm talking about football
or something.
[ Laughter ]
That man is --
Anyway, I tell you what.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
You know, it wouldn't be
the holidays
without Grandpa saying something
that makes you go, "Oh, jeez!
Alright. Alright.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Get him outta here."
Biden's staff was going,
"Quick, turn on the tree.
Turn on the tree!"
[ Laughter ]
An aide was like,
"How did that happen?"
Literally the only thing
on the prompter was...
[ Laughter and applause ]
To be fair, LL Cool J
did play professional football.
In the 1999 movie
"Any Given Sunday."
[ Laughter and applause ]
It got worse when Biden said,
"Anyway, thanks to --
for whatever you do,
L.L.Bean J."
[ Laughter and applause ]
L.L.Bean J.
Meanwhile, today Biden
was delivering remarks
on the economy
and he didn't really
sound like himself.
Listen to this.
-[ Baritone ]
The CEOs of not only the --
[ Laughter ]
the -- the -- the suppliers,
but the CEOs
of UPS and FedEx,
which are on track to deliver
more packages than ever.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That was real?
-That's real, yeah.
There he is, President Groot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Obama was like --
[ As Obama ] Sounds like
the job's got you smoking, too.
[ Laughter ]
Overnight, Biden suddenly
turned into Brad Garrett.
[ As Garrett ]
Raymond, Raymond.
[ Laughter ]
Even Shaq was like --
[ As Shaq ]
What's up with that voice?
[ Laughter ]
This is good news -- last night,
just hours before the deadline,
Congress reached a deal
to avoid a government shutdown.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yes.
A government shutdown.
You know these are crazy times,
when the government
almost shuts down
and most Americans are like,
"Meh.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, add it to the pile."
Yeah, the government is now
funded through February 18th.
It's basically Congress'
version of repeatedly clicking
"Remind me tomorrow"
on a software update.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like, "No, no, I just want
to check my emails. Not yet, no.
Don't update. Don't."
Some business news --
Bath & Body Works'
big annual scented candle sale
starts today...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...and people take this sale
very seriously.
This morning,
there was a 30-minute wait
to even get on the website.
-Ooh.
-It is so popular that,
this year,
there's a limit
of 18 candles per customer,
so you're only allowed to buy
18 scented Bath & Body Works
candles, max.
[ Laughter ]
-Well?
-Well, what?
-Well, what 18 Bath & Body Works
candles are you going to buy?
[ Laughter ]
-That's easy.
It's a no-brainer.
Winter Candy Apple,
Mahogany Balsam,
Mahogany Teakwood, Holiday,
Hot Cocoa & Cream,
Sugared Snickerdoodle,
Snowflakes & Citrus,
Flannel, Fresh Balsam,
Peppermint Sugar Cookie,
Champagne Toast,
Marshmallow Fireside,
Frosted Cranberry,
Tis the Season,
Under the Christmas Tree,
Bright Christmas Morning.
Maybe two classics,
like Vanilla Balsam
and Frosted Coconut Snowball.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Whoa.
Wait, you're not --
you're not getting anything
from Bath & Body Works
White Barn collection?
What about like
Eucalyptus Snowfall,
Sweater Weather,
or Iced Cranberry Scone?
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-I mean, I guess I could see
swapping out Mahogany Balsam
for an Iced Vanilla Woods.
[ Laughter ]
I did have my eye
on that new metallic jar trio
with Winterberry Wreath,
Falling Snow, and Midnight Snow.
I mean, it's two snows in one.
[ Laughter ]
-Plus, come on.
This year's Joy Love Peace Hope
collection?
Two all-new scents --
Iced Raspberry Bellini
and Cotton Candy Champagne.
-Still come with the
Winter Peach Marshmallow,
though, right?
-[ Chuckling ] Oh,
you tell me.
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's my dude.
-Waiting all year for this, man.
-[ Laughing ] That's my dude.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no, wait, Higgins.
[ Ohs and applause ]
Higgins,
[ Laughter ]
are you eating a melted candle?
-No!
I filled this thing up
with pudding.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, okay. Well, what flavor?
-Pine.
-Ah, very nice.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Well, I --
-Mmm!
[ Laughter ]
So good.
[ Slurping ]
-I read that...
[ Laughter ]
Turn the lights.
Turn the tree on!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I read that Zoom just rolled out
a new feature called
Attendance Status
that makes it easier
to see who's at a meeting
and whether anyone
showed up late,
[ Ohs and booing ]
which is why they're
changing the name
from Zoom to...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on!
-Come on, man.
And now Skype is trying
to capitalize on this.
That's right, their new motto is
"Skype --
where snitches get stitches."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, it's the holiday season
and everyone's getting
packages delivered,
but there's one house
in Tennessee
that might have taken it
a little too far.
Check this out.
[ Ohs and laughter ]
Look at this.
Look at that.
That's what happens when you
give a three-year-old
your phone for five minutes.
[ Laughter ]
That's what.
The UPS guy's going to lose his
mind when the owner's like,
"I need to make
a very large return."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I saw that a bride
in North Carolina went viral
for celebrating her wedding
with a mannequin of her husband
because he got food poisoning
on the big day.
Check this out.
It's real. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Their wedding was actually
delayed twice because of COVID
and then, the groom
got food poisoning.
And, each time, the bride said,
"God, if I'm making a mistake,
give me a sign.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Give me --"
Guys, the NFL just suspended
three players,
including Tampa Bay Buccaneers
star receiver Antonio Brown,
for turning in
fake vaccine cards.
The NFL got suspicious
when, under doctor,
it said "Aaron Rodgers."